why did you do it well you know it's all
about the people as far as I'm concerned
it's about my constituents it's about my
country what I've done today is moved to
a party that I think is secure about a
future for them and that's why I've done
it when did you feel that the
Conservative Party was no longer the
right fit for you
I mean look for a number of conservative
colleagues it's been a difficult 12 to
18 months and I suppose it began to
accelerate with the change of
administration I mean ultimately I came
into politics because I wanted to make a
positive difference to leave a legacy
for future generations and and when
you've got a Conservative administration
that's hell-bent on delivering a No Deal
brexit I'm sorry that's just not in the
best interest of future generations as
far as I'm concerned so I've moved to a
party that has always been at the
forefront of trying to stop this
nonsense and I'm very proud to do so
2017 you stood on the party ticket you
agreed with a manifesto then tell me
what's changed is it Boris Johnson in
number 10 no I mean I mean first of all
the manifesto is published after I was
agreed to be the candidate and as often
sort of cited as a reason ultimately I'm
elected to to serve the best interests
of my constituents and that is what I've
sought to do since 2017 I guess the
elevation of Boris Johnson to the Prime
Minister's position has accelerated
events we're seeing that only today the
news is coming thick and fast and I
don't expect to be the last person to to
make this decision I think it's a very
difficult decision 27 years a member of
the Conservative Party
I have friends in the Conservative Party
still and it's a difficult it's a wrench
it's like a divorce and I didn't rush
this decision I took some time over it
but I'm feel positive about it
because I know that I'm in a party
that's going to confront the two big
issues I think that are facing this
country which is brexit and climate
change
you don't expect to be the last person
to leave the Conservative Party tell me
more I don't think that everybody who's
currently sitting as a conservative is
going to be sitting as a conservative
after the next election whether they
join the Liberal Democrats or not it's
an individual decision but I really
wouldn't be surprised if more come to
this conclusion over the next few days
it's not an easy decision for anybody
but those of us who've come into
politics particularly those of us who've
had to fight this fight over many long
hard months I've been interviewed by UK
many times about brexit ultimately we've
all come in to politics to make a
positive difference and I think that a
number of colleagues want to continue
making that positive difference I've
concluded that doing it within the
Conservative Party just doesn't work for
me so you feel several of your
colleagues will cross the floor leaving
the conservative benches and joining the
Liberal Democrats I'm not sure whether
they will join the Liberal Democrats or
not as I say is a private decision but I
do know that a number of colleagues are
searching their souls they have been
doing so for a number of months and
you've already seen just ingredien
announced this morning that she's not
going to be standing in the next
election you've already had kids Obed
say that he's not going to be standing
as a conservative next election there
are a number of us who wrestled with our
consciousness perhaps for too long over
this issue fundamentally we have values
of that are all about making our country
a better and stronger place to be for
the greatest number of people and at the
moment we seem to be hell-bent as a
nation or administration is is in doing
something that I think is going to be
deeply damaging and I was just not
prepared to associate myself with that
project any longer Kay how do you know
doctor that colleagues will be leaving
the party I don't know I just know that
I've had many many conversations over
many many months and I have very good
relationships with a number of
colleagues who've been wrestling with
this for a long long long time you know
they're going to make their decisions
and it's up to them I'm not here to
judge others I've made my decision today
and it was a difficult decision but I
believe it was the right decision the
right decision for my constituents and
more broadly for my country
how do you feel about the Prime
Minister's behavior over the last few
weeks since he took office well whether
it's his behavior or whether it's the
people that he's chosen to have around
him or not I must say I've not I've not
been left with a particularly positive
impression you know it's a tough job
being Prime Minister we all understand
that but you can't go bullying people
certainly not people whose motivations
to coming into politics are deeply
honorable in fact by trying to bully
them you tend to get an opposite
response and I think that's what's
happening I mean ultimately you know I
want my country to be governed well and
to be taken into the future in a
positive way and I just do not believe
that this administration is the way for
that to be achieved and that's why I
have left the Conservative Party and
proudly joined the Liberal Democrats was
there a moment that you thought you
looked yourself in the mirror and
thought I just can't do this anymore I
was speaking to one of your colleagues
recently and he said it was the moment
that a young woman was marched down
Downing Street she was basically
frog-marched out of Downing Street with
an armed officer by her side look he's
been building with me for some time okay
I think you know that but actually
yesterday morning an interview took
place on LBC with Jacob Riis MOG in a
consultant neurologist Jacob Riis MOG
was just disgraceful and his manner and
the way in which he spoke to a member of
my profession so if I'm going to cite an
incident the straw that broke the
camel's back it's that it was
disgraceful it was about ignoring
evidence it was about showing disrespect
for Peter to experts the people with
professional standing with knowledge and
if this is what brexit is about if this
is what this project is about which is
ignoring expert advice ignoring Democrat
democracy trying to circumvent
parliament any decent person must ask
themselves must look in the mirror today
and say I do not want to be party to
that that's what I've done and that's
why I'm proud to have tormented
Democrats will you stand it a
bi-election hey it's not about me okay
this is about the issue I don't actually
think a general election should take
place until this basic issue is dealt
with if they want to call it election if
they can find a mechanism to do so I'm
going to be out fighting for what I
believe in but ultimately by elections I
think general election is probably going
to come at some point and that's when
this is all going to be decided but for
now let's concentrate on the issue at
hand and the issue at hand is stopping a
No Deal brexit that does not have the
explicit informed consent of the British
public that is the project I'm
concentrating on not on my future
political career but given that you are
an honorable man doctor and you no
longer representing the conservative
voters in your constituency isn't a
by-election the obvious next step
actually I think I am representing the
voters of my constituency the
correspondences the correspondence I get
increasingly showing anxiety about the
direction of travel and it comes from
people who've both voted leave and voted
remain the way our system works is I'm
elected as a trustee I'm elected to make
judgments on behalf of my constituents
on behalf of the many many businesses
who tell me from lots of different
sectors that any former brexit is bad
for their future I you know whether I am
a Conservative Party member of
parliament or a Liberal Democrat they
will continue to do that and fulfill
that role until the next election final
thought before we let you go dr. Lee if
Jeremy Corbyn forgive me Jeremy hum
Russians they had had won the leadership
race would you still be in the same
position well it's a hypothetical I mean
I suspect Jeremy be wrestling with the
same things that Boris Johnson is
wrestling with but he probably would be
doing it with a bit more she was a bit
too people around him who don't engage
in bullying tactics so maybe it would
have been different but I think
realistically in time this was
inevitable I haven't left my party my
party has left me
my values remain the same